[Music]
hey you guys here we are with another
tomes of terror book review and i'm
finally getting around to this one so i
had actually been sort of wanting to and
like looking forward to uh reading f
paul wilson's 1981 novel the keep for
quite a while
for several reasons uh one a number of
you guys uh some listeners out there had
recommended it uh heartily i'd heard of
it before but i hadn't read it uh two i
had kind of vague but sort of fond
memories of the 1983 michael mann film
adaptation
although i will admit that i haven't
seen it for a long time so i'm not
actually really sure how it holds up
like i read a little bit like about the
wikipedia page and stuff and about how
troubled the production was and how it
was initially like almost three hours
long and they cut out all this stuff and
it's incomprehensible and stuff like
that so i haven't seen it in a really
long time so i don't know but i
remembered liking it when i saw it back
in the 80s
uh three
i had actually read another one of f
paul wilson's novels i think it was the
tomb a few years back and enjoyed it
quite a bit although i will admit again
that i don't recall a great deal about
it otherwise i just have you know again
fond memories of it
so the keep let me see if i can get this
straight
is actually the first in what was
originally called the night world cycle
but eventually came to be called the
adversary cycle i think that was because
like a reviewer called like after like
several of the books had come out like
used that phrase and i guess f paul
wilson liked that better so he actually
like renamed
you know the series of books because he
thought that was a better name
as far as i'm aware however and i could
be totally wrong about this so please
correct me if i am
the keep was initially written as a
standalone story
and only kind of later became sort of
maybe kind of
retroactively connected to the other six
books in the adversary cycle
as i mentioned i did read the tomb which
is actually the first book to feature
wilson's iconic character repairman jack
and it's also the second book in the
adversary cycle but it doesn't have
anything to do with the keep and the
repairman jack novels also i i should
say also have he has his own series
which later intertwine with the
adversary cycle so you have to kind of
like read them in tandem i think at
least as far as i'm aware uh confused
yet me too so that doesn't have like
that much to do with this book because
like i said this is totally standalone
yes uh it leaves it open where it could
be like
opened up to like a bigger world which
i'm assuming that it did but you don't
need to have read any of the other books
to read this one because it's
essentially a standalone story so the
keep seems to be pretty highly regarded
uh you know in horror circles it appears
on several people's uh and blogs and
stuff like that like best horror novels
of the 20th century lists although i
will note that it also has its
detractors so you know don't think that
it's very much on the sort of mainstream
slash pulp horror kind of end of the
spectrum
uh with nods to hp lovecraft for example
clark ashton smith robert e howard other
kind of writers like that of the kind of
golden era of pulp horror and sci-fi
overall i was really into like the first
maybe half to three quarters of this
book
though i did think it weakened a little
bit toward the end when it went spoiler
alert in a little bit more of a dark
fantasy type direction
i have liked a handful of dark fantasy
or sword and sorcery type uh you know
tales in my day
but it's usually not the kind of thing
that i would generally seek out it's not
usually the kind of thing that i like
i'm very much like a straight up horror
person like haunted house psychological
that kind of stuff you know gore i like
that kind of stuff i don't usually like
a lot of sci-fi or fantasy type stuff
although there are exceptions to that
rule so the story of the keep is set in
1941
in the early days of world war ii
now in the remote mountains of romania
there is this small mysterious fortress
which is simply known as the keep
it's like a castle but many
uh and it becomes interesting to the
nazi high command for very like
strategic purposes it looks overlooks
this past that they think oh maybe
you know maybe we'll need that like
during some like whatever so they want
to station some people out there now the
keeps origins are a complete mystery
nobody knows who built it or exactly how
old it is
but it's been maintained like in tip-top
condition by generations of villagers
for centuries like somebody nobody knows
who
pays like this certain family of
villagers to
keep up like stone masons and stuff like
that to keep the thing like in top
repair and nobody really knows like how
because there's all these
kind of different like steps in the
process of like how the money gets there
so the man who is initially in command
of the german soldiers stationed at the
keep whose name is captain klaus vermont
i guess is how you pronounce his name
he's an older guy and he fought in the
first world war and he's not the biggest
fan of like the nazi party or hitler or
their death camps or anything like that
now very early in the story he actually
sends a very ominous message to the
higher ups like at the ss and it
essentially just says something is
killing my men not someone something is
killing my men so verman's colleague
slash rival who's a guy named eric
kempfer he's the nazist nazi to ever
like wear a swastika he's almost almost
shades over into like a cartoon villain
but not quite
um so he's kind of sent on a mission to
sort out whatever the [ __ ] is going on
at uh the keep
now he's actually gunning for the very
coveted position of commander at this
new death camp that the nazis want to
set up in uh and i'm sure i'm gonna
butcher this but uh ploy ployeshti maybe
uh in romania
and he hopes that by kind of like
bringing a swift decisive conclusion to
whatever the situation is at the keep he
can actually get the desired promotion
he's kind of like in line for it you
know what i mean there's also kind of
another uh thing that's kind of spurring
him to want this position he wants to
make his rival vermon
uh who also happens to be the only
person to ever witness him being a
coward
um he wants to make him look like an
incompetent fool like show him up
because he's older and you know like i
said he has kind of like some dirt on
him the problem though is that the
ongoing state of affairs at the keep is
a lot more complicated than it might
first appear
although when kempher gets there with
his ss guys he very arrogantly believes
that the very gruesome murders of
vermont's men can sort of be attributed
to nothing more than like some local
rebel groups
uh it soon starts to become very clear
that the deaths
are probably not caused by anything
human for one thing
the keep actually seemed completely
harmless like even all the villagers
said you know there's no stories about
like hauntings or you know nobody's ever
died in there or nothing like that so it
seemed like completely harmless until
two of vermont's soldiers
believing that the thousands of these
kind of
funny-looking t-shaped crosses that are
like embedded on the inside of the stone
walls like all over the place they think
that they're made of gold and silver so
they tried to pry one of them loose and
they found what appeared to be kind of
like a secret passage shafty type
situation behind there and immediately
after that happens one of the men has
his head torn off by some unseen force
and after that like the killings start
sort of coming like thick and fast
almost as if something has been perhaps
released from the bowels of the keep so
once the bodies start to pile up um the
officers kind of like try and double up
on security keeping everyone awake all
night and [ __ ] like that but it doesn't
really seem to do any good there appears
to be some kind of being or creature or
something like that that is able to just
kind of like emerge from the darkness
rip off people's heads and tear out
people's throats willy-nilly and then is
able to like melt back into the shadows
they start tearing apart the keep to see
if they can find out where this thing
whatever it is is hiding uh for a long
time they still do think it's a guy or a
bunch of guys but you know the longer it
goes on and the weirder [ __ ] gets
because there's some [ __ ] with like some
zombies essentially like people walking
around that were already dead um then
they're starting to think okay well
maybe there's like some supernatural
[ __ ] going on here so once they get to
that point unsure of what to do and
losing at least or averaging at least
losing a man a day to whatever this
invisible menace is the officers end up
summoning who a guy who's kind of like
the foremost authority uh on the keep
and also of the folklore of the region
and he's a scholar like an older man
named professor theodore kuza
and he also happens to be jewish which
like i said the nazis nazi is not super
happy about having to take
uh you know information or try or you
know trying to get help from a jewish
person so he's a little cranky about
that
now kuza is a wheelchair-bound uh guy
and he's very very ill very infirm he
suffers from a kind of crippling disease
he can't really like his circulation is
bad he can't really use his hands things
like that um so when he's forced to come
to the keep because he is absolutely
forced to come there he's obliged to
bring along his daughter magda who is
about 30 or 31 she's actually a scholar
in her own right she's a music scholar
and she's kind of put her own life
largely on hold to serve as her father's
caretaker at the beginning of the story
she doesn't seem to care about this very
much she doesn't seem all that
interested in like marriage or family or
anything like that she's very studious
and she's kind of like into that more
than you know doing like
i guess what back then would have been
considered like stereotypically feminine
things now hovering around the edges of
this core story at least in the first
half of the book
is this mysterious for a time unnamed
red-haired man
who seems to have some kind of
connection to the keep in the sense that
when the whatever it is is like breached
and you know the creature or whatever it
is like comes out
he actually even though he's like half a
world away he
kind of psychically senses oh [ __ ] like
something bad's gonna i gotta get there
so interspersed with all the stuff going
on with the nazis and the scholars and
everything like that um you have like
this guy who for a time you don't really
know who it is trying to get to uh the
keep without you know it's wartime so
he's trying to get the black without
getting caught so the setup of this part
of the book is great i mean it's really
chilling it's very atmospheric it's very
page turning you're just kind of like
holy [ __ ] you know and it's always fun
to see the sort of like emissaries of
the master race like trembling in fear
or some unknown thing just starts
picking them off one by one uh you know
that never gets old seeing nazis having
their heads ripped off their shoulders
and even though
you know and i think i don't even know
if like the back of the book says this
but i mean the book is from 1981 so i
think most people know uh that this
monster is kind of like a vampire it's
not it's more like a proto vampire
because i think it's kind of like this
is the thing like the real thing that
vampires like all the vampire legends
are based on so some of the vampire [ __ ]
applies and some of it doesn't apply so
it's that kind of stuff so even though
you know that this is like a vampire
adjacent monster like pretty early on in
the story there's still like enough
intrigue and tension and stuff like that
to keep you invested and i will say too
that even though and i've mentioned this
before i'm usually a big advocate of not
over explaining your monster i didn't
even mind and from here it's like kind
of like i'm not going to spoil the whole
thing but i am going to spoil some
things that are plot points so if you
haven't read this or if you haven't seen
the movie or anything like that um then
you might want to click off and either
go read it or something like that but if
you don't care then you can keep on
going
so what i was saying was that i didn't
even mind
uh the sort of demystification i guess
of the creature that took place i guess
about halfway through the book
where it's revealed that the uh the
monster is actually a moroi
which is kind of like a pro proto
vampire like i said like a demon type
deal
uh and at first it calls itself radu
molestar like it talks it's actually
like a person you know what i mean it's
like a vampire it's got like a cape on
and [ __ ] like that the main thing though
that i think was interesting about this
part even though i was kind a little bit
bummed out that i was kind of like oh
you know it was much creepier when you
didn't really know what it was i mean
you knew it was like a vampire thing but
you didn't really know much about it
once it kind of started talking and came
out dressed it was like a little bit of
a
less scary but i still liked this part
of the story because the main thing that
was interesting about this part of the
story was the fact that professor kuza
who was actually like fascinated by the
monster because like i said he's like a
folklore scholar and he's just like
amazed that he's like oh my god this
thing really exists that's awesome and
he ends up like striking up
something of an uneasy alliance with the
monster because the creature
he's essentially makes uh kuza believe
that he wants to wipe out the germans
he's like hey this is my keep i don't
want these [ __ ] in here and
you're from this region like you're from
but he's really really old so he still
calls it like velocia but you know he's
like same diff he's like you're my
countryman and these germans are
interlopers so we're kind of like enemy
and my enemies the front is my friend
type thing so it's like we both want the
same thing we want these germans out of
here we want to wipe them out so there's
that kind of thing so he actually kind
of like sets up like i said like an
uneasy alliance with the monster i also
really liked the
kind of underlying main conflict of the
tale that
even though the monster promised to
eliminate the nazis i mean he wants to
go he says he's going to go to berlin
and kill hitler and all this other stuff
and sort of like end their campaign of
terror
you
eventually discover that letting the
monster win in that way might actually
be way worse than anything the nazis
could have done so i like that this is
kind of like evil but like you know yeah
but then like greater evil you know what
i mean so i thought that was good i know
that's not like completely original but
i did like that angle on it
i also really liked the way that the
monster was able to kind of like
manipulate professor kuza uh who was
actually a very decent and honorable man
into doing his bidding uh was also very
very good very insidious and also like
quite believable so i thought that was
cool
but i will say that once the red-haired
man gets to the keep because remember i
said this red-haired man was like been
like trying to get there like for the
whole first half of the book and every
now and then like you see things from
his point of view
when he gets to the keep and uh it's
discovered that his name is
glenn that's not actually his real name
his real name is gleckin
uh i think that i'm pronouncing that
right but um that's kind of like what he
tells everybody his name is
um so when he shows up i kind of feel
like the story lost a little bit of
steam i mean i still enjoyed it overall
but this is the point where it starts to
go a little bit more like in a dark
fantasy direction and once glenn is
established as a sort of this sort of
like ancient rival to the maroy and it
goes toward a more fantasy style story
like magic swords ancient spells that
kind of stuff i felt like the story lost
a lot of the gothic creepiness it had
when it was just like nazis getting
picked off one by one by like a scary
monster that was like
melting in and out of the shadows like
that was the coolest part like with the
castle the keep and everybody getting
like bumped off i thought that was like
really cool uh also could have done
without the romance novel bits uh with
glenn and magda like them falling in
love didn't really need that i'm not but
you know it happens a lot like in these
mainstream type horror novels where it's
like well we have to like wedge a
romance in there and i'm not a big fan
of that um you know i'm not completely
averse but i don't really like romance
novels and i don't really like horror
novels that have a romance aspect to
them there are again exceptions to that
but in general i'm just kind of like i
didn't need to be in there although i
understand why it was in here because
it added
some kind of complication and also
some more like motivation for glenn in
like what his ultimate goal was you know
what i mean like it kind of like made
his
you know made his mission like that much
more difficult that much more
complicated because he had fallen in
love with this woman so i mean i can see
why this was such a bestseller and it's
so widely beloved i mean it's a pretty
compelling read it's very just like
chock full of these eerie fog shrouded
castles in eastern europe like up in the
mountains it's got spooky vampires it's
got reanimated corpses nazis getting
[ __ ] up it's like you know that's all
those are all like cool things uh it's
not written like particularly elegantly
or in a literary style or anything like
that it's pretty standard
straightforward way that i feel like
every now and then like falls victim to
chronological mainstream pulp horror
cliche uh but that's okay all in all uh
i actually really had a lot of fun with
this one and it actually made me want to
revisit uh the film
adaptation as well which as i mentioned
came out in 1983 and was directed by
michael mann as i said the production of
it was very very troubled um and
i i feel like michael mann didn't like
how the how the final version came out
because the [ __ ] that he shot it was
like like i said it was almost like
three hours long which is crazy for like
a horror movie but there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on in this book so i can kind of
see why but i think it got trimmed down
by the producers to like an hour and a
half so he was like and some people
watching it that hadn't read the book
we're just like what the [ __ ] is going
on i can't really follow it because it
was like incomprehensible and i will
note too that f paul wilson the author
of this book really did not like uh the
movie and he actually ended up in 2005
writing his own graphic novel series
which was illustrated by matthew dall
smith because he wanted to get his own
like vision like what the visuals of the
book that he pictured he wanted to get
that on the page because he really
wasn't happy with the movie adaptation
so there's that but yeah this was a
really good one if you really just like
kind of like mainstream pulpy like i
said like lovecraft or robert e howard
or something like that um it is very
much in that vein like i said it starts
off like the first half of it is kind of
more gothic horror it is a vampire story
but the vampire isn't exactly like a
traditional vampire although it does
have a lot of traditional vampire tropes
in it but again like about halfway three
quarters of the way through it goes
a little bit it goes more in like a dark
fantasy direction and there is kind of
like a romance angle as well which like
i said i wasn't a big fan of actually i
read like a lot of reviews that also
weren't a big fan of that so i guess
like most people that are under horror
were like we don't want romance in the
horror god damn it stop it but yeah but
it didn't bother me too much it wasn't
that egregious so it didn't bother me so
i really did like this one uh overall so
if you've read it or if you've read any
of the other ones in the adversary cycle
and they relate anything to this one
like let me know because i
from what i read about the adversary
cycle and you know because like i said i
read the tomb and that doesn't have
anything to do with the keep it's like a
completely different story completely
different characters and so i don't know
if all the books are really all that
interrelated because this one just
seemed like very much a standalone story
that was kind of like retconned and i
guess they added some [ __ ] later on but
if you've read any of the other ones in
the adversary cycle let me know because
i actually i'm really interested so that
will do it for this book review this
tomes of terror and i will see you guys
on the next one bye